le score final est de à 3 en faveur du
collège
champ ils sont content les élèves du
collège champolon de voisin le bretux
ont remporté le trophée du 14e
championnat intercollège de match
d'improvisation théâtrale c'est
trèsurisant de ouf c'est c'est vraiment
un grand plaisir d'avoir gagné ça je
pense que je parle au nom de tous
l'improvisation c'est vraiment génial
c'est c'est un grand plaisir de libér
aussi on pe on peut se lâcher un moyen
d'expression ça ça permet de
s'exprimer que ce soit en improvisation
ou en vrai quoi c'est c'est trop bien
organisé par la compagnie desclic
Théâtre depuis maintenant 14 ans cet
événement intercommunal ne désemplit pas
ce sont en effet plus de 150 collégiens
qui tout au long de l'année participent
aux ateliers d'improvisation dans 10
établissements scolairires
cquantinois au-delà des valeurs que
transmettent ces ateliers il semblerait
également que leur succès ne soit plus à
démontrer les poulins issus de l'écurie
Déclic Théâtre aujourd'hui reconnu du
grand public en sont l'exemple concret
ça me rappelle donc mon enfance quand
moi j'ai commencé avec la compagnie
declic théâre à l'âge de 11 ans comme
j'ai pu le dire tout à l'heure c'était
Nono mon mon premier coach et de voir
qu'il y a toujours autant d'entrain et
ben ça fait plaisir on a envie de
parfois rentrer dans la patinoire jouer
avec eux et être source de proposition
aussi aujourd'hui je me base beaucoup
sur des textes mais quand il y a
certains certains réalisateurs qui qui
nous disent bah si tu as de nouvelles
propositions pour ton personnage vas-y
bah c'est une source de proposition
l'improvisation théâtrale puisque j'ai
fait des films où j'ai improvisé des
scènes qui sont restées à l'image donc
du coup quand on les voit au cinéma on
se dit que c'est écrit mais en fait ça
vient de l'improvisation et ben c'est
pour ça que Déclic Théâtre m'a beaucoup
beaucoup apporté j'y suis toujours la
compagnie je suis là la preuve à chaque
événement j'essaie d'être présent
certains des jeunes en compétition ce
soir-là sont peut-être les talents de
demain